now the big question is Andrews mustache
I love his beer thank you very no one
loves his beer Thank You person Thank
You radios Bradley Cooper man thank you
Thank You Lee Bradley Cooper I like it I
know is really good you found something
more horrible Troy likes in my beard too
except he won't a minute on the air
because you guys are now best friends
trepkos drawing one you guys looks very
natural that's a nice look you enjoy our
best friends now so you agree on
everything because you guys think that
because you have each other your sex
addictions are okay that is a good point
[Laughter]
married no kids right you guys can be
our Mercedes I'm living a fun life at 50
right you guys can get together and be
like oh what a weirdo Sam is like look
at this text I got look at that and it's
like come on guys
so they're bullying you for your
normalcy very much so I don't mind as
inb as normal so yeah it's it's the
beard it's I can't do awful today yeah I
would love to see a nice little beard on
Jim every girl I've ever been with
it may help define a chin for yeah
that's dude it's our makeup exactly it's
our version of makeup oh my god oh line
give yourself you know yeah I look at
photos of me now and I ain't even been
that long
but I look at photos of what I look like
without a beard I am horrified you are
more handsome with this beer thank you
very much full up top because of the
beautiful that's an optical illusion
because you're you're drawn to the
abomination below that's all it is it's
like starting a fire in the basement so
the roof esta Jimmy not a basements just
on fire yeah no I appreciate I think
you're right Andrew yeah and I'm like
gasps he's good no he's dead because he
doesn't have to say this stuff it's more
than polite this is how he feels
yeah I think it looks I think it looks
better I think it defines your face I
think you look like Bradley [ __ ]
Cooper thank you Joe would you be a
voice of reason here goddammit we get
shitload
no I like it thank you thank you yes I
mean it's it's whatever he's I'm very
indifferent I'd like does he try to
shave his no we should see that I knew
Travis when he was clean-shaven yeah
yeah of course
young young eager boy yeah twenties yeah
oh man full head of hair fall out of
hair he did you never want to do the P
you want to go on the vitamin P no what
no I didn't care vitamin P is like
Rogaine yeah a piece of probation so
finasteride is us veteran there's no
[ __ ] your penis up though yeah does it
do you take it yeah I've been taking for
10 years wait right I got in early man
my god I was watching a don't say oh my
god like I have a whole nah being a good
head of hair they're actually a good at
1/2 it isn't incredibly [ __ ] your dick
up though um that's what they say but I
think you just kind of go through it and
then I also got this new thing they
sponsor well I don't want to do a
sponsored up but there's a thing called
blue cheese viagra yeah yeah you know
I've done them and it just changes
everything dude it's like there's never
any one of the door guys the seller
tried to sell me viagra once I was like
you find this is a psychic for you all
right I got you on this blue Chu I've
never taken a Bluetooth I'll bring it to
the Sun for three milligrams it's a
circle
alright I don't know I take yoga I take
hundred milligram before me I take 20
milligram [ __ ] sales I bite him in
half well we take half a day I take half
of them which one did you pick did you
pick the cialis version or the viagra
verse oh so you know about you Mary I
know about hey I'm on I'm in the podcast
Game two we get free greet you in the
podcast game wait a minute I never got
one I've read them from I promise I'll
bring you a pack this week and yeah what
what shocked it for was shocking for me
is that um the assumption was your dick
feels good you come right this [ __ ]
allows it to be hard feel good but you
have kind of control that's what I'm you
can choose when you come I don't want to
say choose cuz that's maybe overselling
but I had way more control
so I might be able to go longer than
seven minutes oh dude you got this plum
you want yeah I want all my sex to be
1/3 an episode of shits Creek which is
better the tadalafil or the whatever you
want Sylvan but uh the cialis works like
cialis in the sense that you take it and
then you know it lasts whenever you need
it and the cell is it a little deal it's
my size too like if you take Cialis
don't think about that seldom Phil or
whatever like that it just do it
apparently look I try to not look inside
of XK that my brain gets going on yeah
for sure I leave them smart but I so the
side effects of this yeah you just
amazing in bed and no but I mean at like
afterwards is there anything like if you
stop taking it or something like that I
mean I won't take it all the time I take
it almost like a party drug you know
what I mean right it's just like or I
take a little Molly take a blue cheese
you know I should take them like
literally two three or four times a week
now I take K I mean like like [ __ ]
Viagra and Cialis Jim yeah well I've
taken two in the last six months used to
take see how it's like a multivitamin
like it was just what he ate with his
dinner
take my cialis just in case just in case
someone bumps my dick with a shopping
bag on the subway constantly getting
rods in here oh yeah blue ones what
Jimmy's wearing sweatpants and he's like
look I got a Sai Alice rod the Chicago
right Legionnaires disease outbreak yeah
yeah I can't help but house is awesome
so I'm all about that in the propecia
man I'm all about it it's amazing what
it does did you have did you have an
issue and then you took it honestly my
hair so my hair grew back I was doing
some show I forget what it was I was uh
it was on some like no-name [ __ ]
channel but I remember watching it and
like I kind of like bent over and
laughed and you know how the lighting
yeah right on your face but now it's
right on my hair and it was just like
seeping through oh my god am I going
bald but there's a girl back in the
right places you're not getting hair on
your back or anything or nothing dude
that's how that's crazy
is it a pill yeah it's a pill and what
happened it's not for hair originally it
was for uh was it for it was like no
kidneys or some [ __ ] or liver it was I
think prostate drugs that's it prostate
yeah so there's all these people who had
like prostate cancer or something like
that and they were just doing these
clinical trials and and all the sudden
start growing their hair back they were
still dying from Canada but they would
have this full head of the second I
found out I was like [ __ ] I might as
well I know if I have a choice not to
lose it how long did it take to be
effective dude I would say pretty maybe
a month Wow every day but if you're
already but if it's already happened
you're [ __ ] like it doesn't to me it
started to go and and from my look
everybody's different but for me it kind
of uh yeah brought it back how quickly I
would say maybe like a month but I'm
telling you it got full like I was doing
weird [ __ ] to comb it over and it was
something I was insecure by was like
[ __ ] is this it is it over I'm young I'm
25 at the time I'm not ready for this
I'm not ready right and then I take
someone like that my eyebrows are gonna
get even bigger though you're a great
head of hair you do not need any balding
at all it's been over for a long time
what you mean just never been that good
with the ladies but that's okay are you
trying to [ __ ] on the side a little no
job Mac you got a beautiful girlfriend
that was my 20s without a girlfriend
I know we've spoken about yes I was I
was shocked how long your entire 20s
mm-hmm were you a virgin at that point
yeah oh wow Wow and this is you were
making good money you work in corporate
America a Priuses you could have had
girls what are you doing I was never
good at it like you know what it is it's
mostly if you don't if you don't like
yourself it's hard to get other people
to like you so it's hard to if you're
not confident it's hard to I was always
like even even now and I see Sam talk to
girls
after she doesn't like wow you're really
good at that I'm just terrible and you
don't understand why
so confident yes looks like you just
gotta have a drunk tank so what changed
but you got this chick of yours oh you
know she asked asked me if I wanted to
hang out that's helpful is that so
that's the best no no no I wish we met
it - Caroline's though Mackey and I used
to run a weekly show at Caroline's and
after you did Last Comic Standing women
were coming out form like crazy TV yeah
he's adorable and they think oh my god
this guy's safe yeah I saved a nice boys
like I was famous for like two months
and Sam and I were standing outside at
Caroline from this person is like oh hey
and I was like yes I'd like one did
something totally unrelated she didn't
know who I was it was the most
embarrassing best feeling when someone's
like someone's like we take a picture
and you're like yes I will and then
they're like no Abbasi yeah yeah yeah
it's really bad when that happens yes
now propecia making me think man I'll
take a look might be too late for me I
don't think so dude I got a little bit
how are you good coverage up there bad
but it's a good coverage I don't care
that dodging sugar you eat sugar no very
rarely your hair grows back have you
stopped eating sugar
again I'm not like a scientist guys no
no but I'm just like I'm doing
[Laughter]
for everything it kind of bums me out
though cuz I like sports like when you
hear these nineties players they like
yeah we did cocaine the night before now
they're just like they're off sugar
mm-hmm I want to I want to talk to you
about this actually is that why they
were fighting in the NBA every single
game every game was like a like a little
fist fight and I think it's because they
were coked up maybe yeah they was right
before bias goes down right he was just
yakked up right that was like a wake-up
call for the league though when that guy
died cuz they were like holy [ __ ] you
just died at 18 that's how [ __ ] bad a
drug coke is no but guys taking a
negative how many people do cocaine
still play good basketball they were all
coked up yeah I mean I don't know Lenny
Dykstra [ __ ] a Gooden strawberry
Keith Hernandez those guys did drugs who
was the coach of that team a manager
Davey Johnson Davey Johnson's right man
did you see speaking of the NBA did you
hear who the latest person to question
the moon landing is Steph Curry as he
was on some podcast and on the ringer I
think and he said that he had heard that
Kubrick is the one that filmed it he
believes the Kubrick theory that Kubrick
filmed the moon landing now Jim and I
talked to Kubrick's constant assistant
although he wasn't with Kubrick at that
point nobody was 68 he didn't believe
any of the Kubrick conspiracy theories
he didn't think there was any secret
meetings in The Shining he didn't
believe any of them and he thought it
was absolutely absurd that Stanley
Kubrick filmed the moon landing but they
can't tell me why they little Danny and
The Shining has an ASUS sweater on hold
the hollow what is the Nats of hopping
have to do with anything nothing
he's an Apollo sweatshirt it's a
spaceship I guess it was before Apollo
went up nose in 1980 was too shining and
Apollo was 12 years earlier people think
it was his it was Stanley Kubrick
Danny's wearing our shirts Rallo you
know Stanley Kubrick's way of saying I
filmed the moon landing
or it could just be because someone in
wardrobe foot was adorable that a boy
would wear that okay both paws Lee both
awesome here's my question
tell me is it possible that we did go to
the moon we did in fact land there we
didn't get a good video of it we come
back home yes we need to have a video of
it hey there is a theory that we did got
one that is one of the other theories
yes you didn't go that's also incorrect
but yeah there is actually
oh it's incorrect that yeah they filmed
it absolutely there was up there yeah
happened did some people think that we
did go to the moon but in order to make
it digestible for people the footage
just didn't look like someone told me
we're taking off
and who would film that part like
someone said you you see the the rocket
ship take off from the moon in the video
and it's like do they just leave the guy
oh yeah and then he just faxed the
footage pretty convincing about how they
shot that and then it shows what the
moon footage looks like and then you
know how you see the sea so you tell two
guys they get a joke ever though they're
just like hey you film it and they just
leave them on the film is leaving and
then we'll come back and get you but
it's weird like because they would have
ran out of steam up I thought I had a
thought that I just lost interest in it
it's just because wherever you see a
documentary that goes after the
conspiracy theories because I don't know
enough about technology so you watch
like one of these are holy [ __ ] but then
when you watch a video made by someone
who knows and zeez and Wilson Vince was
on the gig and we're in the car and the
guy who picked us up just no hesitation
just starts going into conspiracy
theories and he's talking about the moon
landing and like great detail were like
and we get started to tell he's like a
little crazy and were like huh uh-huh
and then we try to change the subject so
we're like what's good food around here
what everybody got and he's like he's
our someone like thank God and then
we'll goes where do you stand on 9/11
an [ __ ] question yeah all this
conspiracy documented you're right you
always find the response and and there's
a documentary that disproves the first
one yes same thing with all the food
documentaries you can find a documentary
that will tell you not to eat any food
that you want to not eat if you believe
them all you will never eat you'll never
don't eat corn though that's a good one
I thought king corn I was like now I
could buy one vegetable so why no corn
corn stay away from the corn bro it's in
everything in it's full of sugar it's
yeah it's just like it first of all
they've just done so okay okay two ways
to look it's real quick first of all the
GMO thing I'm not like anti GMO you got
to feed 300 million people in America we
got to figure out a way to do it what's
the crop you know in China they're like
let's use rice in America we're like
iron we don't got rice we got to do
something corn boom that's good they
start you know messing with the genes of
the actual corn and changing it so much
that we can't really digest it that's
why comes out in your [ __ ] right you're
literally not digesting the food you put
it in your body it's it's one of the few
things they like you eat and it looks it
looks the same okay so usually look down
after I throw it like to do I'm not
gonna get two girls but sometimes I'll
wipe and squeeze okay that's too gross
did you say you weren't a scientist so
but but yes so we're not digesting it
and then they start making all these
products out of this corn that we
already can't digest so like the the
corn syrup right right and then they put
the corn syrup in everything but the
more syrup in the sodas it's there and
apparently like our carbon makeup I
think they said this in the documentary
if you take a piece of your hair a piece
of your hair basically shows what you're
built out of right and we're 90% corn or
something we are corn that's dope
it's kind of dope I cut out [ __ ] corn
I cut out sugar and I cut out bread and
I know it sounds corny as [ __ ] dude but
dude it really changed my like mental a
little bit like I used to have to go to
the gym just to be normal I'm gonna call
them I had to get this excess
energy out of my [ __ ] head and I
stopped eating all this kind of sugar
and I use sugar based products and like
burn like oh [ __ ] I only have to go to
gym I go that it's it's nuts man you
feel better
dude I know I sound like everybody in
those stupid [ __ ] infomercials like
about the benefits of going whatever I
swear to god man I made a change for me
I don't know if anybody else but keep it
like you know what makes me feel good
what's that my kicks in your ass I mean
that was really specific so many certain
differentials I guess I need to make but
I like eating bad food that makes me
feel good sugar that like I'm I feel
good though there's something that's
right eating at McDonald's it's [ __ ]
rule it's awesome soda that's it's the
best but you you might be different than
me you might be able to maintain that
kind of calm way better than me so your
body is equipped for it Manny that hair
looks like that that beard looks like a
good healthy corn beard thank you
healthy corn beard oh wow I paid dearly
for that [ __ ] you don't get into
conspiracy theories really besides food
hmm cuz you strike me as the type
because you love what you love a hot
take I love a hot take and I love you
know challenging conventional wisdom
that which is the conspiracy thing yes
but I feel like with the now now I don't
I actually kind of like they care so
much about it
to take it away from them I see I know
it's more satisfying to watch someone
who's invested in it be heartbroken
yes yeah so like with the 9/11 [ __ ] I'm
just like you know how hard it is to
keep a secret right like keep anything
private amongst the five of us you think
you could keep this entire government
conspiracy that would take hundreds of
people to make happen
I would hold masturbation segments
without divulging after the 9/11 that
was absolutely you sound like a comic
pretending to not know what he's talking
about talk about the internet now the
inner tube no no no it's also great when
they have all this data and information
they're like whoa there was this and
this happened on this date and this
amount of that and you can hit them back
with logic that is not research but just
something like that that you can't argue
with like yeah but that many people
couldn't keep a secret yeah and it's
like you're right all this research I
just the flatter thing is is weird yeah
you know like I love that one what's
being what's the purpose of making it up
like why would I say there what is the
purpose of sound the earth is round it
depends - no advantage it depends some
people have different a lot of people
think that not only is flat earth flat
but in the middle there's aliens and so
oh I thought there were asses okay right
and so you want the world to be round
because otherwise you'll see the alien
hole I think so I look I don't know too
much about it but uh I think in a four
dimensional reality technically the
third dimension would seem flat so right
now you live in three right right so if
we added a fourth dimension to that this
third dimension that we live in would
seem flat right so and there are more
than three dimensions so you could make
the argument that but what about there's
more than four if there's more than
three eleven I think he's with
they say whatever like theorize 11
that's the best that's the best you know
reason for it but you know some just
some fat dude and his [ __ ] underwear
that's saying the world is flat I don't
think he really knows exactly what's
going on with it
people love the idea that they've been
lied to the whole time because then it
means they're onto something it's easier
to control a lie than it is to just
accept reality you know what this is
this is like like the me to movement but
for men tell me they're just bored
activism for men but men don't really
have like causes so we have to like
think of science [ __ ] white men
specifically yes Flat Earth is across
all races well yeah yeah I think you
find a lot of a lot of black guys you
know we're coming together Jim
absolutely yes that's right holy that
was it Kyrie Irving wooden soldier boy a
flat earther or no b.o.b yeah he'll be
was a flat earth yeah - yeah but Shaq
says some dumb [ __ ] just for attention
sometimes yeah he likes to just get
people talking
but b.o.b was like a hardcore flat
earther yeah they went really for it and
then cat what's-his-face Kyrie took it
back he did just like Steph will
eventually walk back this awesome
harrassing yeah it's it's like you're a
fool yeah yeah very very wealthy fool
though doesn't matter
definitely not believe in evolution
because of the religion thing yeah he's
one of the guys that are like yeah we
were walking around diner 6000 no they
only said that once dinosaur proof
became so undeniable for a long time
they denied dinosaur this didn't exist
they were fake planted and then all of a
sudden people like would be a [ __ ]
dough pizza no we lived with them good
adjustment this might be the dumbest
question in the world but like why
didn't the Monkees also evolve what do
you mean right so we separate from these
chimpanzee right we start evolving we're
in the same areas them it's not like we
left them right there's still humans and
chimpanzees living pretty pretty close
cut proximity to this day why did humans
for whatever reason start becoming smart
and like walking upright or better
aliens what Troi is more of an aliens
knew they were tinkering with our DNA
and they've been around for hundreds and
hundreds and thousand
white activism that is white active
anyone the sim was incurring is white
after battle star Galactica fan you guys
don't get that okay going out get down
your lick my [ __ ] yours for the car
wrecks yeah I don't know I mean I think
all all species evolved somewhat you
know they're missing link to we don't
know what we need to find the missing
link some people theorize it's me
they have been it has been said on the
internet yes that I am indeed yes he is
before he is the right part off human
and homely that's right yes yes I don't
think it's true but uh yeah that there
is there is some like that's what
Bigfoot is right isn't Bigfoot supposed
to be linked but ya know why would he be
the missing link because there was a
combination of ape and human he just
walks upright he's not a combination he
still looks more like he said oh really
is a guy in a uniform he's a guy's name
was something Johnson yeah he admitted
it famous footage where he's like [ __ ]
running in the woods and a linear foot
yeah there's other Bigfoot that's the
most famous footage from 67 Bigfoot's
not just a name first of all yeah there
are people who truly believe in Bigfoot
one of them Charlamagne tha God
Charlamagne jinx that percent believes
in Bigfoot I remember once at a birthday
party his wife got him a Finding Bigfoot
like they were gonna go do it why does
he believe in Bigfoot
he believes in a lot of different things
he does he's a Bigfoot now he's too
famous now to still go on his Bigfoot or
- no no believes in Bigfoot he's like
it's there find that famous footage it's
uh from judges put - a Bigfoot judge on
exactly as Bigfoot
it's the missing link the Sasquatch the
yet a it's basically like a gorilla that
walks upright so in anymore human DNA
and more human DNA than like a regular
girl so it's in between gorillas in us
Jim Keegan's cart can you get the
correct sign Freddy so you'll be great
yeah um hey isn't it weird that they
call him big they focus on his big feet
when he looks like that Oh
[Laughter]
there it is that's the uniform any
lights back it's a costume did
Charlemagne the guy believe in Loch Ness
monster no but um my family Scottish and
there is some belief in it the sir your
family are just in Scotland in my family
but I think the belief is more economic
than anything the sergeant's photo is a
fake he admitted on his deathbed that he
faked that photo yeah that's just the
one call the surgeon for the most famous
one of the shadow yes the surgeons yeah
yeah yeah yeah just it's just like it
brings so many people to the reason that
there's no reason to go there besides
that so they're nice exist definitely
that's getting like the royal family for
England it's like it's there for tourism
it's not there right the next show
anything exactly
it's kind of weird to think the Scottish
people's royal family is that is it's
kind of crazy to think a giant monster
could hide in a lake it's just an
[ __ ] issue so the thing about this
lake though is these lakes are like the
deepest ones in the world yeah I think
that's what they're don't think Channel
under the like ocean and there's this
weird places I believe I believe but
they're so deep that you can't check the
whole thing at one it's just some weird
the mythology kind of fits that it's not
like it's the reservoir and you know
Central Park and you want us canal but
there was a [ __ ] picture of the Loch
Ness monster underwater
yeah and it's obviously like a log or
something look for a lock this much
underwater another one it looks like a
blurry face in front of a camera so
that's so bad lake is so deep that
there's enough room for a monster and
that's the scientific evidence that
there is a monster down there you go
back up have a reasonable doubt I guess
by that logic Cloverfield is definitely
real because you could put a clover
field at the bottom of the Hudson right
yes yeah I didn't watch the last one do
I need to watch the last one the Netflix
one yes no it wasn't very good okay
that's not the Loch Ness monster it's a
[ __ ] log I think that might be Nessie
Nessie
I'm gonna go Troy you a Nessie guy okay
yeah aliens might do you think the ad is
it possible Troy that several several
hundred years ago the aliens did come
down and one of them had a pet Loch Ness
monster and they left it in Scotland
the massive comment Troy well you know
like all those things were like old
times where they have like a horse with
a human head right a lot of people say
that aliens may have been trying to make
a mix match then you say they believe in
the Centaur so huge are you thinking of
a liger yeah it's a combination of a
tiger and a lion right bird skills and
magic yeah yeah but is it possible I'm
saying that they had a pet Loch Ness
monster that they left in Scotland and
they just the way et got left behind is
that possible very possible okay Troy
question what if what if aliens didn't
tinker with our DNA but what if like
some sort of asteroid [ __ ] hit a region
of the United States right there were
some chimpanzees and then the chimpanzee
started interacting with that asteroid
that had these properties from another
planet and that sped up our well wasn't
the US had started I would guess would
be Asia or Africa or a burg where humans
were born yeah or might have been Asia
was that kid from Columbia and he
actually said the wife even though he
said white people started all he did yes
the European European European had many
started what society people everything
they started society the modern world
yeah Oh modernity no yeah yeah but
didn't they isn't the isn't modernity
isn't that Paloma Diaz he didn't he
didn't he was drunk he raised us yeah
yeah yeah it could skew that way you
know he's just proud of being white
weighs it [ __ ] yeah white people are the
best white man [ __ ] you say it but if it
was anyone else saying that about their
ethnicity but alright the guy but it
wouldn't no big deal cuz it's not an
ethnicity that's what people get it's
like you could say [ __ ] yeah I'm Italian
you can't say [ __ ] why well I should
say right if you've yours if you're
black or Mexican in your selfies and why
blacks can say is because they don't
have this a lot of them don't have this
attachment to where they were from they
can't go [ __ ] yeah I'm from Ghana cuz
they don't know if they're from Ghana
cuz they were stolen right right like
white people we know it really calm and
it's like I had stopped somewhere in the
1800s I can't tell you it's not in
Virginia yeah yeah
yeah guys uh Nance interesti or 23andme
or any of those I they they keep begging
me to do it you won't do it I'm like
nobody wait a minute this could be fun
I would like I'm curious what do you
think you are sexual preference listed
on my ass I'm a mostly Irish with a
little Italian I'm sure there's some
maybe some Scottish Mike yeah it's
probably just a bunch of just European
[ __ ] makes I'll do it just to do it but
it doesn't mean anything
yeah I mean I don't think you're gonna
find anything besides Sam you're adopted
right so this was like my mom raised me
I was legally adopted by a ghost
yeah no I'm not adopted like an
orphanage oh I thought you were like an
orphan yeah Bob Kelly to do it because
Bob was adopted he's convinced himself
that he's Irish and at least you're not
Irish what do you think he is I don't
know but he's merely vanish berto Rican
right yeah oh that would be I mean have
you seen photos of young Bob Kelly yes
by the way best Roseline best best roast
like Colin said that Colin said that Bob
Kelly looks like something you buy in
the gift shop of the Beijing Airport
yeah oh my lord we should definitely get
Bob Kelly he is let he's poor he's
Latino
Marie of course yes it would be
interesting to send one his Caravan he's
totally Karin I'm dying to get Bobby's
[ __ ] because he look at that picture
in the middle up to the second one in
the purple background that's not an eye
Rahman he's not Irish he is not Irish no
he's not he's not I do Irish people give
up their kids for adoption yeah do they
sure there's exceptions are they even if
generally speaking maybe not that often
but there's good there's guys sure if
you're like a I mean you're a teenager
and you get pregnant it might have been
there Irish that's when they get
pregnant you're not married I mean 4050
years ago it might've been a big deal he
is not look Italian at all no he's not
Bobby Kelly might be Porterie yes I
think he is he we gotta get this piece
I'd be interested to see if he leans
into it
you know I mean especially now my whole
life yeah it could be good to be Latino
maybe he starts getting you know good
stuff in the biz absolute identities he
wasn't kidding he definitely would lean
into it by the way changes podcast so
you know what I say dude let's let's get
him to do it we should ask Bob to do it
I think it's a good idea I haven't done
his podcast in a long time is there a
way to where we can get we can get some
of his DNA without him knowing and then
break the news to him live is that what
did you Nick need higher or something
like that what do you think we're gonna
get that from him exactly I need a straw
hurt what about your sweat plenty of it
yeah I'm sure we'll need that wouldn't
be tough I spit
yes spit you could get to never do it
you're giving your cup your DNA to a
company we should just tell Bob to do it
and then we're gonna break the news to
him live on the air
he wouldn't do a great idea what do you
think they're gonna do Joe you think
they're gonna build a little Joe
Mackey's no but in the privacy pop in
the in the in the policies it says we
can update we can change this privacy
policy whenever we want so obviously
they're putting that in there for a
reason that there is value to having
people's DNA development or whatever
it's also great because if there's a
[ __ ] crime committed some [ __ ] kid
rapist they got DNA from ancestry they
can use it good you're not worried about
that
no use that I think to get somebody yeah
they have serial killer there's a
there's one minor killer yeah yeah DNA
where you can find you can try to find
long-lost relatives right here DNA so
anyone could search it and the cops use
familial familial DNA which is they
could say oh we don't have his DNA match
but we found someone who's related to
him so wait a minute so they did that
they just put on there because somebody
in his family must have used that
service yes and all you need is about 2%
of the population to have their DNA and
anything you can find a familial DNA of
almost everyone in the whole country so
ok jeez good holy [ __ ] that's what
they're trying to do mm-hmm
if they get 2% they know every single
whoa
they can create a database it's not a
criminal database anymore it's just a
database right and you just don't know
what the future is going to be so when
you when you let someone else hold the
key to it everything about you then
they're the gatekeeper no I agree with
them ai is not good I'm gonna have my
DNA I'm an enemy and this is why we
didn't know what Facebook wasn't we
signed up for it and now look at what
they've done there I mean there's like
four hundred thousand pages of
information and all of us there's not
four hundred thousand pages of
information about me well they have a
lot of mess yeah you're right they say
they say you could you know more about
what is it if you if you know ten things
somebody likes you know more than their
friends if you know twenty things they
like you know more than their family if
you well 300 things they like you know
more than they know about themselves so
why even though they advertise now it's
like when you walk to the store they can
tell if you go a certain route if you
give your location in your phone so they
know when to advertise they were like
wow yeah by a store they're like they
hit you with that store I never get my
location
keep your location sure we'll have you
look if you've never used like you used
like tinder and stuff no but I use it
only for those apps i regulate which
apps and then Facebook never Twitter
never but if some of those apps are so
on your information okay go got busted
you turned off your location from Google
and they were using the your where you
were where you were searching for
something on the web on your phone they
were tracking your location with that
even though you would Google yeah you
baby I your IP address so they would use
the location of the IP right instead of
the location right phone that oh wow
yes they were telling you you told them
don't track me and they said we're not
tracked to it but they were still
tracked it's all for that movie movie
past thing to apparently do is company
yes I invested heavily in it
apparently I never got it but apparently
you could only booked your ticket if you
were within a certain 200 200 feet or
200 feet someone and the whole reason
why they did that was they wanted to get
data on what you purchased when you were
around the theater so that they could
sell that to real estate companies they
were looking to that was their plan was
to lose money on the movie tickets and
sell the data and then everybody was
like we don't want your day
we have enough and then they were like
we're really [ __ ] who is that oh there
was enough information out there that
they didn't know less they're not making
any money you know what I mean like
they're they just came out with another
new set of plans where it's because they
they were they were trying they were
tricking people into not being able to
unsubscribe yes from movie paths because
they're losing so much money so I think
that they didn't realize the information
is already there everybody's already
using all their customer loyalty cards
it's all out there you could tell they
were family when it was like you know
you they no longer let you pick any
movie right yeah you'd want to see one
movie they'd be like that when you
rather see Slenderman at 9:00 a.m. now
they've changed it so you can pick any
movie again but you can pay a little
more and you can only do it three times
a month instead of 30 the original plan
$9.99 for 30 every day they were going
to the movies they figured people yeah
nobody's gonna use it now like no we
would definitely use it yeah we're bored
all right that many movies I want to see
that's the other thing is they neither
yeah a good foreign film how come you're
yeah can you push back and results
against yeah yeah I a I um I don't buy
it I don't think that they're gonna be
angry at us why not well they're not
gonna be angry the premise that they're
gonna be angry at us is based no no
Jesus but not angry thing else your your
miss for me okay it's not a notional
when you get in the film or process it's
when you evolve right yeah to a place
where like you just don't need yeah this
other thing yeah Jim you have to take
that [ __ ] I stood up and your things
after [ __ ] that's actually a great cool
will be obsolete like once we don't once
they can program each other yeah like
what's AI is building AI yeah
and they've received all the information
that's in our puny little brains cuz
that's gonna take what a month
yeah we're obsolete once so what so what
what's wrong human beings are obsolete
yeah we serve no purpose yeah they'll
kill us off there's walk we're gonna
still want to make babies okay then we
won't serve a purpose right okay so what
so if we don't serve a purpose and we're
not in their way and that we're not
harming them from doing anything they
want to do what's the big deal you're
willing you're willing to sacrifice your
position at the top of the food chain
there's a
a lot of different theories going on at
the top of the food chain who's at the
time we are Ebola Ebola yeah like those
diseases that just kill everybody that's
that we have no cure for that we can
contain them and kill them off quickly
what they get for tea we kill them off
for dinner they don't grow they don't
spread should we stop them pretty well
hazmat suits you know I mean we're
pretty good with the population of human
beings is not suffering yeah well
there's a thing called the paperclip
theory where you you develop that little
guy that helps you format your Microsoft
Word documents that's good that's a good
thing um this is like we're a robot is
programmed to make paperclips and you
give it yeah the ability to learn
machine learning and it it tries to make
paper clips at all costs and I start
procuring more and more materials and in
its in its haste to create more
paperclips it just destroys humanity
because it has to get metal from
everywhere and it doesn't because oh no
reason to it yeah yeah a horrible theory
no that's that makes it's not paper
clips what a thumbtacks I mean it's it
doesn't have to be a paper clip it's the
idea that a robot will do whatever they
have to do there was a machine that was
a rope robot computers are developed it
to uh to win chess matches yeah and it
beat Deering s broth yes deep the second
one beat well they built an another
compare that they didn't teach the rules
of chess it gave it machine learning and
now that robot can beat the robot that
was all whopper was was good at beating
that was designed to be a good chess
suit when you create machines to learn
you don't know what they're gonna do
with that information which is what
we're doing already
like look at spell check on your phone
yeah like it learns to how you type by
the way I also don't like the in an
email when you type an email and it
finishes yeah I don't like that don't
tell me hey I'm my and then it will say
way soon whoa [ __ ] you don't yeah when I
got an email back that says no problem
exclamation point I go you didn't type
that that's right you just clicked the
option one hand in it okay so you're
gonna be there just move brother mover
and shaker you're gonna be the guy who
just allows AI to take your spot I care
giving up you're laying down I'm so
ready man
you can have it I'm so let me ask you
something you don't need Tollbooth
workers yes all them bro
they're all gone not a Labour job you
got yeah I mean leave you thriving job
that's a thing you know must as a hero
now but he's about to be like the
biggest villain in US history in like
the next ten years when you go to the
mall to put nine million Americans out
of work with the driverless car parking
lot attendants how many none one usual
I'm not in a mall put the ticket in
putting the ticket out you nothing I
think like how uber is like destroyed
the yellow cab right but and then you're
just saying the driverless cars unless
Abreu has driverless cars I mean even
they do they were there putting people
out of work think about not only drivers
cart it's trucking where it gets real
serious right there's like three million
truckers actually that's where they're
doing the driverless cars first because
that's really gonna save their money
exact also they won't they won't get
tired right they'll be able to drive a
lot more they won't be all cranked up
although in that movie cars the truck is
a living being and he does need a nap
otherwise the your lightening ends up
you know in the [ __ ] route 66 give us
he trucks the Stephen King it was called
Maximum Overdrive fault that's based on
a short story called trucks which is
really if the trucks for last year's
disappearing they're gonna be gun to but
here's real that's a shame about the
cars said this is an interesting no one
hunting at the end of the experience boo
so they go maybe it's your attitude the
driver so the driverless car the drivers
truck whatever this is the tricky thing
the the car or the truck is designed to
protect itself right and it calculates
what will keep itself the safest right
let's say you're driving and there's a
little kid on the road in front of you
right mmm veering off you veer into a
tree and potentially hurt yourself
smashing that kid you preserve yourself
and preserve the car way better and this
is what you're advocating for a hundred
percent and that killing kids isn't that
fun I want to do it that's what the car
is gonna do and now what's the liability
right who pays for that what insurance I
think that's where it's going to be hard
to transition into driverless because no
insurance company is gonna want to take
on a smashing kid vehicle because it
would have to be the the insurance of
the company who made the car correct I
know you're gonna want to take that
responsible they'll all take the
insurance you know why because yep I
think you don't here's why here's why
because the odds of it happening will be
astronomically lower than human error
that's
true people like it's like when a car
has a proper car the problem we're gonna
tell you the right tire comes off what's
is it cost effective to just let the
right tire come off when we get sued a
little bit or to recall everything they
do those calculations and a lot of times
I'll say [ __ ] it let the accidents
happen because the lawsuits won't cost
as much as recalling the car and
furthermore it since it's safer right
since these driverless cars are actually
safer than human beings they don't need
to be perfect they just need to be 5%
safer right and they will be and they
will be eventually they start to go hey
humans you driving that's a liability
we're gonna need to take your license
humans aren't allowed to drive anymore
because it's too dangerous purposes I
think it's done but I think you can't
wait to sit in the driverless car how
amazing is look at my played with a my
[ __ ] way to a gig by yourself doze
yeah I'll take a nap in my [ __ ] car
oh you know you'll get there no more
traffic because every car communicate
with each other exact you turn Wi-Fi
exactly how long it's gonna take there's
no accidents nothing right because you
know why you know why because the
computers are in control they're in
control yeah not you your wife that's
like a day I know that's no different
hey do this do that that's true but at
least she's a human but she's machine
one time she takes me out from time to
time no I mean like kill you these are
gonna do no they need you for what I
don't know I think that far into it
that's almost like the plains of tape
people let's think computers are gonna
kill us off wait please what the [ __ ] is
a plane of a jet plane ever show up at
my house I just get on it and we tell it
what to do and it does it that's what
Isis should say I don't know if that's a
great example no planes have been flying
themselves forever mm-hmm they in
themselves they can't think they do you
really think that the pilot is doing it
Landon they they are yeah but just for a
last-second [ __ ] but a plane could land
it's of course they can do anything
turbulent anything meaning take off plan
yes of course we pit the pilot lands
every single time I think so yeah yeah
but with with assistance mm-hmm yeah I'm
saying the heavy lifting is probably
done yeah thank you do it yeah they can
approach flare touchdown track to say of
course they can what was that story
Travis about the the bear repellent that
went crazy in the Amazon robot factor or
the robot that punctured bear repellent
and almost killed like you know two
dozen Amazon workers and guess who
doesn't care about that the [ __ ]
robot they killed all those wait what
happened robot punch your bear repellent
yeah I'm at an Amazon warehouse I think
in Jersey a robot accidentally exactly
that shirt that's a rough job and Amazon
where the reason we get everything in
like 24 hours no good yeah but by the
way that is not a good job don't worry
about it everybody who has those jobs I
they're gonna be the first to just be
homeless instead dude that's what I'm
saying with labor jobs it's like if you
have a Labor job those are some of the
last jobs you can get without a college
education and those are gonna be gone
done skia there's a that Amazon guy
Bezos obviously smart dude but I heard
apparently he knew he was gonna put the
office in New York the whole time but
what he was doing is pretending he was
gonna put in the other cities so that
the cities would give him hit their data
mm oh this guy is data data mining all
the cities are yeah we might do I won't
you tell me what kind of purchases you
got going on what kind of flights you
gotta go on in this kind of [ __ ] he
mines all this data from all these
cities who are dying to get the Amazon
Center and then you know you know you
you know how people sell things on
Amazon independently of Amazon like I
said I know that but like an e-commerce
guy if you create a product right if you
want to sell Andrew Schultz hats
consignment kind of sales yeah right you
can sell your Andrew Schultz hats
through Amazon but the deal is we'll
give you the platform everybody's here
you give us your sales data
okay cool no problem what Amazon and
then they find dude they've done it
they've got a history of doing it they
find your sales data they go Oh Andrew
Schultz hats are selling really well
let's make our own version of Andrew
Schultz hats and we'll sell them a lot
cheaper than you can because we're
Amazon and they put you who was using
their service out of business just
because tech tech app I POS have
decreased because of Google and Amazon
have so much clout that they just do
what you do better rights it's harder
harder to start a tech company right
what are you working on over there how
would you do it ourselves yeah it's
crazy and a new well
in AI that's the whole argument with the
free market right you don't want these
massive businesses because they [ __ ] on
the the startups ya tech world and the
oil world whatever it is yes it's
there's two conflicting ideas in
business they're given both job there's
deregulation and antitrust and business
is one both they want deregulation but
no antitrust so when a company like
Google gets big they like don't regulate
don't realize lead us but if you still
want to have competition you need
antitrust we we kind of been lacking for
since Roosevelt yeah no I yeah it makes
it makes yeah it makes perfect sense
it's a weird world but let's go Amazon
we'll listen now that we figured it all
out put them all out of business port
faster at those warehouse that's right
god damn it give the robots whips hurry
up hurry up